hey guys trying something new this week
I've had a crazy two weeks if you follow
me on Twitter lots going on I think some
big announcements coming in the next
little while but this gave me a good
excuse to do something with my friend
david pacman you guys know David he is a
big youtuber we agree on a lot of stuff
we disagree on some stuff and and he
knows his stuff so I thought we'd do
kind of a round up with some of the
stories that I was interested in this
week and some of the things that he
wanted to talk about so first off I
wanted to start with Bernie Sanders
because you know we just did this whole
series with Mark a mandir from the week
sort of breaking down the best of the
worst of all the presidential candidates
and everybody in the comment section was
gone more Bernie more Bernie more Bernie
so pac-man as a progressive your big
progressive does Bernie Sanders have a
chance I seriously hope so I mean if we
look at the polls we do see that he is
doing far better than many people
expected we see that Hillary Clinton's
favorability is at its lowest point and
I think it was 12 or 14 years I've I
just had an interesting discussion
though on my program you know there was
this NPR interview where he was asked by
Diane Rehm or not even really asked you
just sort of presumed Oh since you're
also an Israeli citizen type of thing
and I was just waiting for when the
Jewish factor would become a factor
because uh for years I've said broad
picture there's going to be a female
president before there's a Jewish
president and it just so happens we're
now looking at Hillary Clinton and
Bernie Sanders in the Democratic primary
and I think that that's going to become
more of a thing the better Bernie does
yes so I i heard that interview and
everybody's making a big deal of attic
so first off it sounds like she sourced
this information that he's a dual
citizen of Israel from a Facebook post
from some crazy anti-semitic website
originally um what what do you make of
the question itself like the accusatory
tone it really wasn't a question it was
a she stated it sort of as fat yeah then
he immediately went on the attack
because he is not a dual as he said like
that dual citizen of Mexico or any other
country he did admit to having gone to
Israel
which is incredible that he had to
clarify listen I happen to have been to
this country but no I'm not a citizen
and I was just wondering what when else
would someone like Diane Rehm very
respected on NPR also very respected but
take such a presumed bit of data which
in this case is false from a facebook
post in other words with the same
standard be applied to asking i don't
know Ted Cruz if he's actually a citizen
of some country in Central America I
don't know right so what do you make of
this thing with the left because I do
think there's huge percentage of of the
far left is definitely either
anti-semitic and and they hide a lot of
that in just hating Israel I don't think
they hide it particularly well uh but to
me it seems obvious that something like
this was gonna bubble out of the last
and and if Bernie no question about it
and I'm now starting to get a lot of
voicemails from my audience saying hey
David do you really think that this
country is going to elect a Jewish
president and it sort of I have to kind
of disaggregate the two the two sides
this on the one hand if you look at
polls Bernie Sanders is the mainstream
candidate he's the guy i wrote a
huffington post blog about this earlier
this week that has been doing really
well the views of the average american
are actually most in line with bernie
sanders not with ted cruz or whoever
else we're talking about but at the same
time there's no doubt that on the left
and the right there there is a sort of
anti-jewish element that may be
connected to israel or it may be
completely disconnected from israel for
many people as well and it's absolutely
a factor yeah i think it's pretty
disconnected actually they just use
israel as the excuse so anyway so all
that being said so I agree with you you
know this 99 percent one percent thing
getting money out of politics all the
things that I do like about progressives
yeah Bernie's hitting that talking you
know police state surveillance all that
kind of stuff big banks um so all that
being said do you think the guy has a
chance cuz frankly i don't i'm gonna say
that he does have a chance i think that
if we look at the money that he's been
raising if we look at the the the
reaction that didn't even it almost
seems like even his own campaign is sort
of surprised by the reaction in the
crowds and the money that's coming in i
am going to
optimistically say that I think he does
have a shot here to sort of pull himself
up slowly but surely and I'm hoping as
the debates get going that that will
just accelerate this right so that's
where I think if there's any chance for
him to me it seems to be the debate sort
of how like last time Newt Gingrich got
this real first in the debates because
they saw him as this guy that was
speaking very clearly and good with
quips like that's where Bernie can use
sort of his Brooklyn roots sense of
humor and just directness where Hillary
is going to be kind of robotic I just
don't think that there's a chance he can
beat that machine Hillary machine we
know that when you have more money in
politics you usually win so from a from
a merely empirical sort of analysis of
the data it's a pretty big hill to climb
but i am i'm sort of hopeful that while
Bernie Sanders shares many of the
characteristics with the sort of uh
unique candidates in the past that have
not altima tlie done that well I'm
hoping that he's different enough in
that he he may be able to catalyze
enough support yeah so last thought on
this do you agree with me that to me the
best the best option we had we had to
pick two candidates to really have a
debate of ideas would be rand paul
versus Bernie Sanders that then you have
two candidates who truly have ideas
ideas that are outside of the mainstream
ideas that sort of cross partisan lines
versus if we get like a Hillary and a
Jeb Bush like it's just the same old
stuff is there any chance you're gonna
get a Sanders Rand Paul you said okay on
Sanders so give me give you the ramp all
thing to Rand Paul will definitely not
be the Republican nominee there's no
question about it although I agree with
you that while I personally disagree
with so much of what Rand Paul stands
for that that would be one of the more
interesting debates and that it would be
Outsiders from the sort of but
conventional wisdom although like i said
the american people agree with Bernie on
more than they know yeah they really do
all right well I want to know what you
guys think I hope that Bernie stays
around at least long enough to change
the discussion and force Hillary left on
some of this stuff and make her
different than the Republicans because
sometimes
hard to tell if she has any difference
than some of the Republicans anyway let
us know what you guys think in the
comments right now